hello I'm Burt from Ramallah college
doing my mechanical under graduation my
question to you sir this how good is the
correlation between amantha being a
scientist and engineer good for
humanities so of course this correlation
between scientists and rejoice necessary
you use certainly computer and telephone
and so this the computer is based on
result of funnel research may be such
years ago 20 years ago and he's using n
this fundamental discovery had been
transformed into device that can use a
verdict thanks to ingenious and sank to
the industry so this correlation this
cooperation between both community is
very fruitful